my name is jean-claude manny i'm proud
of medicine and endocrinology
at the faculty of medicine and
biomedical sciences of the university of
iowa de
cambro i've been dealing with diabetes
since
1990 so you understand that i've been in
a diabetes field for a long time
i have seen people dying from type 1 and
type 2 diabetes
because of lack of access to medication
to medical treatment to care
in sub-saharan africa diabetes
especially type 2 diabetes
has emerged as the most important cause
of morbidity
and mortality this is a region where
in the early 60s they said diabetes was
rare
but nowadays diabetes is so common that
you see it
everywhere on the continent in fact if
you look at the
idea of diabetes atlas of 2019
you see that the projection of
sub-saharan africa
is exponential if you think that
diabetes would increase from 19 million
to about 47 million from 2019 to 2045
which is an increase of 143
which is a region with the greatest
increase in the world
i think i think part of the hypothesis
what is happening is that
as we have embraced uh economic
development in sub-saharan africa
we've lost some of our cultural norms
that is walking
riding we didn't used to have cars we
used to work on food
diet was mostly uh not refined
carbohydrate things have changed now
so we've changed the way we live we've
changed what we eat
and then we are physically inactive i
think i think if you live on the
continent
where uh there is no social insurance or
health insurance system
where the patient has to pay for that
drug even when you have chronic disease
like diabetes
then the situation is alarming why do i
say alarming
because in type 2 diabetes for example
you need the tablets you need monitoring
and then you eventually need insulin
and if you think about the modern
treatment which are the oral drugs and
some injectables they are not found
everywhere
in fact in most of sarah and africa they
depend on
generic drugs that does not mean that
some people cannot afford it there are
rich people there who can afford best
drugs
but there is also the problem of
accessibility if you live in the rural
village which is 400 500 kilometers from
the center
it's difficult for you to have the best
drugs
we know that type 2 diabetes is about 80
85
of the general prevalence of diabetes so
most of the people with diabetes in
sub-saharan africa
have type 2 diabetes we would have all
the genetic drugs like metformin
like sophomorials that are present in
most places
but access to new medication new proven
medications which would reduce
morbid mortality in type 2 diabetes are
uncommon
because the people the patients cannot
afford it or the governments cannot
procure this type of drugs with that
mega
health budget i think uh if you take the
rest of the 15 percent above
about 15 18 percent who have type 1
diabetes
and i must say that type 1 diabetes in
type 1 diabetes you need insulin for
life if you don't have insulin you are
going to die
this is the most crucial part because we
know that
so many children are dying in africa
because they lack insulin
and this lack of insulin is more
prominent especially in the poorer
coach of our society where people cannot
have a pay for the medication
in sub-saharan africa we have a two-tier
system
one which is the infectious disease
system where it's fully funded a patient
with an infectious disease like hiv aids
has
everything at that disposal and free
medication free tests
but if you have a non-communicable
disease like diabetes or high blood
pressure
if your family cannot pay for your
medication
for your treatment you are going to die
because there's no
universal health coverage for those two
diseases
something has to be done to reverse the
situation when
we have one healthcare system taking
care of everyone in the
communities i think one of the important
things in the
history of diabetes is the development
of insulin
about some 100 years ago how many people
really
still benefit from that discovery part
of the problem in
the 1921 is that children especially
with type 1 diabetes were dying
because of lack of access to insulin has
the situation changed in africa
slightly but people
and children are still dying because of
lack of access to medication
insulin and other diabetes supplies so
100 year anniversary of insulin should
mean that
we should have universal access to
insulin
this is a drug that can be manufactured
it's complex yes i know
but there can be international
solidarity to ensure that
those who need insulin
have the insulin wherever they lived in
the world
if you live in a high income country and
you have insulin and people are dying in
low-income countries because of lack of
access to insulin
what are we celebrating 100 anniversary
of insulin for the rich or for the poor
what you need is international
solidarity international solidarity like
the one we had in hiv aids
were the world bank governments private
sector
donors who all came together to procure
medication for hiv and today hiv
has been transformed into a chronic
disease why can we not do this
for diabetes especially type 1 diabetes
access to insulin as we're discussing
the 100 years of the discovery of
[Music]
insulin
you